une mobilisation nationale contre le
pass sanitaires à paris quatre cortèges
ont défilé parmi lesquelles des gilet
jaune et florian philippot à la tête du
parti les patriotes
il faut absolument pas que ce pass
sanitaire parce c'est de la
discrimination pure et simple et dans le
pays qui prétend être celui des droits
de l'homme c'est pas normal qu'ils aient
des restrictions pour faire la
différence entre des non vaccinés les
vacciner c'est complètement hallucinant
quand on en est là on se demande après
ce que va être demain moi je travaille à
l'éducation nationale et moi je suis
très inquiète de ce qu'on va sortir les
gamins qui seront pas vaccinés plus les
personnels à qui on va dire au bout de
deux mois bas vous allez voir ailleurs
parce que vous n'êtes pas vacciné
moi je suis vacciné mais j'estime que
c'est mon choix et chacun doit avoir le
choix
si les rassemblements se sont dans la
majorité déroulée dans le calme
quelques échauffourées ont éclaté entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
montpellier reims ou encore marseille
pas moins de 180 villes de l'hexagone se
sont mobilisés à toulouse et à nantes
les manifestants ont rythmé la marche
d'un cri commun liberté je suis là parce
qu'il ya des incohérences un incroyable
et tout ces privations de libertés sont
insupportables accepté à vivre on
m'empêche d'aller à la piscine parce que
je ne suis pas vacciné on m'empêche
d'aller danser on empêcherait les dents
l'été après tout ce qui fait d'eux le
bien-être de la vie et ça c'est
inadmissible parce que c'est notre corps
c'est pas une guerre entre les vaccinés
et le non vaccinés qu'on mène à l'heure
actuelle
c'est une guerre pour notre liberté il
ya des choses assez grave qui sont en
train d'évoluer de se passer dans le
pays c'est pour ça que je suis là ça
fait plus de 40 ans je suis pas venu
manifester et l'âge pour la première
fois je reviens parce que je suis je
suis un peu effrayé de ce qu'il est en
train de se passer
une mobilisation qui ne semble pas
impressionné le gouvernement ce vendredi
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin s'est exprimée en amont des
manifestations je constate à paris comme
ailleurs une mobilisation qu'il faut
relativiser puisque on parle de 150000 à
200000 manifestants si je fais un
parallèle avec les 4 millions de
personnes qui se sont fait vacciner
au lendemain du discours du président on
constate que ces manifestants ne sont
pas majoritaires un mouvement pourtant
compris par une majorité de la
population sortie ce vendredi une étude
de l'institut harris interactive dévoile
que 51% des français comprennent les
revendications des manifestants
mais seulement 40 % d'entre eux
soutiennent le mouvement